next up we have ryan treadwell he's the
lead producer
at aspire and wouldn't you know just a
little while ago we got the announcement
of a remake for star wars knights of the
old republic so ryan i guess my question
is is this like a a remaster of the
original game or what's going on here
it's so much more sid
this is a complete remake of this
beloved star wars story for star wars
knights the old republic remake we are
rebuilding from the ground up while
maintaining that integrity of story and
character from the original so ryan how
much of a remake are we talking about
here i mean is this updating some
graphics adding some some higher
resolution modes you know the original
star wars knight nightstall republic is
a true classic and one of our favorite
star wars stories ever we want to honor
that original story and make it as
impactful for players today in terms of
the visuals we have an opportunity to
present this story with a much higher
level of fidelity than was possible in
the past while making sure that we're
being authentic to what players loved
about that original game so we know
aspire from bringing classic star wars
games to modern consoles
but this is a much bigger project than
anything the studio's tackled before so
what can you tell me about the team
behind the game you're absolutely right
while aspire has enjoyed a great
relationship with lucasfilm games
through our work bringing classic star
wars games to new audiences on modern
platforms this project is on a
completely different level to anything
we have done before
that's why we knew we had to assemble
the right team to do this project
justice
we put together a team full of industry
veterans from fan favorite rpgs even
including the original star wars knights
of the old republic
it has been a really rewarding
experience to assemble such a talented
team to bring back an epic game
of course we're also working closely
with the amazing teams at playstation
and lucasfilm games
together we couldn't be more excited
about what we'll be able to show you in
the future all of us are of course huge
star wars fans too one of the nice parts
about building a team to make a big star
wars game is the ability to instantly
bond with all the new people of your
favorite aspects of star wars we all
have different star wars memorabilia
behind us in every call and it always
sparks up a good conversation
all right thanks ryan very exciting
stuff and i'm definitely dying to see
more of that one thank you sid it will
be some time before we're ready to show
more but we're very excited about being
able to reveal more in the future all
right and that's it for our show